Marvel Studios She-Hulk attorney at law
has some smashing visual effects which
is why I'm speaking with VFX supervisor
Shannon Justison and Dottie Anderson hey
folks all right well let's jump in now
there are some unbelievable visual
effects in the series what was the most
interesting thing about working on the
series I think the most interesting
thing for doing the VFX for a show like
this is that we have a CG lead and that
has never been done in a Marvel
television show before because it's a
little crazy I mean it's a huge show
they're digital humans involved so
you're creating something using a lot of
input data and a lot of performance
capture But ultimately it's a CG
creation that's going to be acting
alongside actual human actors it was all
about making sure that we had everything
in place to get the best performance
recorded so that we could deliver on a
She-Hulk character that represented
Tatiana's acting still in control no
overwhelming feelings of Rage no a
normal element of Rage so you know
walking into that room you are going to
have a fully CG lead character where do
you start so if you're going to create a
fully digital character like She-Hulk
there's sort of two streams you're
pursuing at the same time the first is
viz Dev which would be standard for any
sort of CG character we have a visual
Development Department here at Marvel
they look at all the comic books and
they look at how our story is telling
her story and then the other side of
that is that we look at our casting the
important part of this is that we need
to know what Tatiana looks like in order
to be able to transform her in and out
of She-Hulk we Envy a fact subject her
to a lot of scanning and photography
that then goes to build stage that goes
through multiple steps of development
making the model look as as real as
possible just in terms of like a
physical proportions and the physical
aspects of it so once you've done all of
that digital work you have Tatiana
maslani's performance how do you pair
the CG and her performance together we
captured petabytes of data it was absurd
how much data we pulled off the set we
actually had a really big onset VFX team
just because we had so much data
acquisition to do when we're recording
mocap and HMC onset we've got several
sets of data that we're actually kind of
picking up so the mocap data actually
records not video but it is straight
data and that is purely data that's
recorded to a digital skeleton so if you
had walked over to the mocap brain bar
while we were recording you could see a
little skeleton running around doing
Tatiana's or Mark's performances which
is pretty wild once you have all of that
data and footage how do you bring them
together into a scene to create a
realistic She-Hulk performance in order
to make She-Hulk more lifelike we always
start with the animation first because
for a character like this that's the
foundation of everything that is to
follow I mean there are so many things
that we consider when we're trying to
make her feel as real as possible people
we try to make it as close to what
Tatiana did as possible and really see
what the essence of each one of those
performances is so starting from the
edit then we can start working from
selects based on the selects we would
for instance we say we have a She-Hulk
shot this is the shot the editors have
chosen this is the mocap performance all
that goes over to a vendor and then they
start their process of tracking the
plates ingesting the mocap which means
transferring the mocap data to the
She-Hulk rig and yeah the thing that's
most exciting is just seeing it come
together seeing it come to life it's a
long process you know we would start by
post visiting and where tachana would be
walking around in her mocap suit we
would then put in a She-Hulk in a kind
of a low-res quick turnaround post of
his form so that could start to inform
already while the animation team is
working away the shaders team is working
on refining all of the look of her skin
texture her hair texture her clothing
texture were building out her clothes
we're building out her shoes then really
once you get turned over and start to
build that scene and see the things
coming to life you start to match the
lighting you start to see the
performance go on the actual She-Hulk
animation puppet it's super exciting
seeing that character come to life once
we have an animated performance that we
like and the studio buys off on at that
point we start all of what we call the
Sims the simulations that's where we
start the clothing simulations the hair
simulations and because all of that's
driven by the animation we don't really
start that until after the animation is
complete you know She-Hulk has so many
different looks I imagine that's a lot
of work how typical is it for a CG
character to have that many outfits yeah
so She-Hulk has 25 outfits which is
crazy amount of different outfits like
usually CG characters will have one
maybe two she has to be in court she has
to be casual she has to be kind of
working out but you still get to have a
lot of fun with like how do the clothes
transform what happens to her shoes each
one of these outfits has to be digitally
created it has to have its simulation
there'll be multiple layers to it in one
of our episode She-Hulk turns up at a
Gala event for a female lawyer of the
year and she is wearing a sequined dress
she helped gala dress the sequin dress
it's incredibly complicated and
terrifying to build in sichi the dress
is mind-blowing it is so amazingly well
done I think there are over a million
sequins that sparkle they catch the
Light correctly they have to like be
form-fitting on her they have to flow
with the dress I'm just constantly aware
of when I'm reviewing those shots just
how like what an achievement it was to
make that dress oh my God that thing is
incredible it's so well done it really
is so incredible and you know the whole
series really is so special what are you
most proud of looking back at this
entire series I'm really excited for
people to see this character I'm excited
for kids my kids to see her and yeah
just being involved with kind of
bringing to the screen so many shots of
a digital human I am very grateful for
the opportunity to be involved with
something so big I really feel like it's
been an honor to be part of the She-Hulk
team especially as the VFX team I love
origin stories and she's such a fun and
like witty and she's meta and she's just
such a great character so to be a part
of her origin story is just a privilege
Oh Shannon and daddy it was such a blast
getting to talk with you a bit more
about She-Hulk and how you bring her to
life thank you so much and of course
everyone make sure you go watch all
episodes of Marvel Studio She-Hulk
attorney at law now streaming only on
Disney Plus
[Music]